hello and welcome to this video at a
call a hakuna so not sure if I should
have sprung the bangko on him yet i
don't think so i played him very often
but probably mostly in my pre banco time
quincy too okay i'll definitely take but
i wonder after you for i do i play in
normal like these six or do I go e 6 cm
v6 is probably not bad but there's
nothing particularly wrong with adopting
the standards set up especially if white
plays Knight c3 voluntarily it's more
interesting if you have fun screen c2
stuff with the night only three years is
a bit more but more interesting okay so
95 I think 95 Knight b6 9 p-6 yeah ok
Knight a5 doesn't work am NOT a five
night before and then I take on d5
should be okay I also could have played
night you fired but after 95 takes takes
bishop 86 he wins a tempo which is not
necessary to give him
it's a bit of an issue really he doesn't
want to trade strategically speaking and
um yeah if you move the night again
you're clogging up your position quite a
bit
okay I think I can do this first e 7
cannot be taken him okay so night before
or not rugby 7 is also interesting and
maybe do that cover it from the side and
then the other look also to be a queen a
five
okay we should age 6 I can even draw
back okay some five coming I don't know
this was my movie anyway threatening 1c3
just bishops III now it's not easy to
meet it doesn't have p3 available on
whatever I don't don't quite see I don't
see a really good move that's what I'm
trying the same this is working why it
looks looks a little bit strange to be
honest so we should be 4i can also just
take and take a tool this is probably
strong
yeah I can just take it very simple and
it works I think 20 x bit too is quite a
quite a serious threat ooh k 3 I can
take that doesn't work Andrew hangs on
be 10 it should be a win I think how is
he covering his his stuff he isn't
covering his stuff so rook be one would
be normal move here we should be seven
know that losers right yep when you have
something better and probably not
I thought that doesn't work
I thought Queen a one and then f6 I can
also just trade everything to be honest
okay with f6 is that working 6mm just it
doesn't work actually check okay I can
also trade everything check
get ready for king yourself okay so
let's win this d5 pawn
white resigns yeah there was a very
straightforward very straightforward win
here out of this he he just played it a
little bit too javid and took maybe too
simplistic first of all I think it's
it's an idea to not put the night here
to have night a three sometimes this is
kind of interesting because you can
sometimes you can recapture on see
forward the night but ok didn't do that
and here 9 p-5 is the most interesting
way to play blocking this immediate
trade off him and maybe play for ok and
I think here I'm already ok yeah as I
said you don't want to take but I think
I mean this I thought isn't doing
anything not sure about this move
because it's seven hangs but I can also
just go back and attack the night again
and this just doesn't work in yeah
getting the pawn so he took it yeah this
is already i think very comfortable very
comfortable I used to somehow improve
around here because it's lost two or
three moves later this is what he played
yeah I don't know this is after the
after Queen a5 I think it's over yeah
the engine confirms everyone loses yeah
maybe be 32 ok i have this yeah i mean
it's a fantastic position for black
everything's active everything's
positioned how it should be positioned
yeah yeah it's basically over
and so I mean I saw this the computer
gives this move now this I forgot about
the Hat threatening this one this is
very nice ok ok ok ok I had think I had
seen this move but I thought after this
I only calculated f6 and I didn't quite
I wasn't quite sure this is netting me
much in comparison to just taking but of
course this is nonsense i have this move
that's very very cute checkmate ok ok
but you know this ending check is a
complete win yeah you have night before
the a pond runs f5 ok this helped a bit
of course because now I'm just winning
the podium but I think going to the
ending wasn't terrible on from practical
point of view but of course in situ is a
lot stronger it ends the game right
right there ok guys thanks for watching